Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David
Pakman Show, I'm Farron Cousins sitting
in for David Pakman this week. Let's get right
back to more news, and what happened on Monday
was it was revealed that Donald Trump is suing
New York Attorney General Letitia James to get
the investigation into his company shut down.
Trump's lawyers, in their filing argued quote
the lawsuit. Was politically motivated, and the
mission is guided solely by political animus
and a desire to harass, intimidate and retaliate
against a private citizen who she views
as a political opponent. She, of course,
being New York Attorney General Letitia James.
This is without a doubt, in my non-lawyer, expert
opinion. One of the dumbest legal arguments I've
honestly ever seen. This investigation has
already resulted in criminal charges, criminal
charges against both the Trump Organization
for Tax Crimes and CFO Allen Weisselberg.
So how on earth are you going to go to court
in front of a judge and say, Judge, listen up?
You know, this investigation that
is going to put our CFO in jail and
causing us some legal headaches with the
organization? Well, it's politically motivated.
The judge is going to look at that say, but
but there's there's criminal charges like it's.
It's bore fruit. We have actual results
from this criminal investigation that show
criminal wrongdoing. So how are you going to
sit there and tell me that this is a witch
hunt when we've found witches? You know,
I mention this over on my channel, fair and
balanced. Donald Trump might actually have
a pretty good case for legal malpractise at
this point. That's how bad this argument is.
Now here's the thing. If this investigation, which
of course, has been going on for about two years,
if it was going on for two years. And they
couldn't find any evidence of criminal wrongdoing.
You may have a very slim chance of being
successful with this particular argument, right?
You know, if you're looking at something for
two years and still can't find anything at all,
you've pored through the documents, you've had the
depositions and you have nothing, then that's a
good sign most likely that there's nothing there.
But there is a there. There's there's a there,
there and there is that there have been criminal
charges on tax related a. I guess you would call
them activities. So you can't say that this is
purely a political motivated stunt when you got
a guy that's probably going to jail for this.
So the question comes down to timing, right?
Why, at any point in the past two years, Donald
Trump could have filed this ridiculous lawsuit
and said, You're coming after me because I'm
president, you're a Democrat, you hate me and blah
blah blah. He could have filed a lawsuit after the
charges were filed against CFO Allen Weisselberg.
And of course, the Trump Organization itself was
also indicted. But he didn't. He waited till now.
So now we get to put on our speculator glasses.
And try to figure out why. My best guess?
And again, this is just my hypothesis. Is that
there's something big coming down the pipeline?
Why wait till now? Probably
because, you know, something.
As we know, they've gotten a hold of
Donald Trump's financial documents.
We have seen that this investigation seems to
span beyond the state of New York at the moment.
You know, there's incidents in Chicago that are
now also being reviewed. You've got some actually
also happening up in Rochester, New York. All
of it centering around the same thing. Did Trump
and his organization lie about the value of their
properties to both tax authorities and the banks?
Was it tax fraud or was it bank fraud?
Or maybe was it a little bit of both?
That's where they're looking at up in Westchester.
That's what they're looking at over in Chicago,
and that's what they're looking at in New York.
Bunch of different Trump owned properties that are
all being investigated for the same thing and with
what's happening in Westchester, for the record,
they've got the proof they've got his presidential
filings where he showed the property was worth one
thing and they've got the local tax records where
he claim it's worth something far less than what
he claimed on his financial disclosure forms.
So maybe that's what it is. Maybe the walls
are closing in a little too quickly for him.
Maybe there's too many investigations going on,
and he's doing what he can to file this ridiculous
lawsuit to maybe stall it a little bit because at
best, that's all he's going to do. This is not
going to get this lawsuit thrown out of court,
but it may slow it down a bit. It may
allow for a little bit of appeal here and
there. It's going to get tossed out of every
court it goes in front of. That's a given.
Again, because the argument is very stupid. But it
may be just enough for Trump to delay it enough to
maybe come up with a decent legal argument
for when things finally go totally sideways